personne
n'a le rendez vous était pourtant bien 3
meur
c'est toujours pareil dans cette île il
tente est incapable d'être à leur
ôtant tout ça
or quelle préparatifs au mais je vais
pouvoir vaincre la montagne
bonjour à tous
serai je promis au rendez vous à nos
fins car je suis déjà là depuis dix
minutes à vous attendre à tout ça au pur
sur madmoizelle tout et ça n'a aucune
importance
l'essentiel il faut se préparer aux
efforts qui nous attendent donnez la
moselle quand je contemple cette
montagne devant moi je me sens tout ému
c'est vrai c'est vrai dire dire que dans
deux heures ne seront pas plus gros que
des petites pour nous s'était formé tout
fébrile les deux facteurs week-end à
fourmies oui vous ne voyez rien mais où
mais là mais pas la femme vers les
rochers un peu plus à droite la la
qu'est ce que c'est
c'est peut-être des bêtes sauvages des
bêtes sauvages vous croyez au nombre des
facteurs ne croyez pas qu'on ferait
mieux d'aller faire un petit tour en
bande s exercer mon sens cela mais bon
vous voyez vous allez région évidemment
il ya les crabes mais c'est moins
dangereux tant m
bonjour les alliés ça va tu vas te vous
êtes déjà prêt bravo et quelle joie et
quel enthousiasme
vous devriez peut-être mieux vaut
couvrir parce que nous avons claqué déjà
des dents avant de partir qu'est ce que
ça va être une fois arrivé là ou
là où ça bouge pardon si on me regardait
plutôt françois regarder aller oui c'est
vrai j'avais oublié de vous prévenir
nous nous sommes divisés en deux groupes
alors premier groupe casimir monsieur du
snob et isolés ils sont partis ils
reconnaître le terrain
aux
sons trop loin ils peuvent pas
m'entendre et le deuxième groupe julie
boudeuse et moi même
julie n'est pas là bon en attendant
vérifions nos sacs
[ __ ]
rien ne prouve que ces petits points
noirs soit casimir monsieur du snop est
joué
personne ne sait quelles espèces
animales d'amour vivent dans la montée
pour cela alors ça y est oui il a bien
fait rire françois oui à votre avis
n'était ce pas dangereux de monter sur
la montagne je pense à mademoiselle
julie oui elle est si fragile dites moi
vous vous inquiétez pour julie ou bien
vous avez un petit peu peur on peut en
revanche pas du tout pour la la la la
pas du tout féler france en mieux je
vais partir devant rouge je vais vous
précédé les amis
bien moi je vais partir aussi alors
écoutez fa cup je bats toi le grand bois
et je vous retrouve dans la montagne
bientôt on va revoir tout à l'heure à
tout à l'heure tous les deux au revoir
bon eh bien moi il me reste attendons
julie
mais que peut-on bien serge july les
autres sont arrivés ronda montagne et
nous ne sont même pas encore partir
françois
mai mais julie que t'arrive-t-il mai
mais pourquoi on porte tu tant de choses
mais mais mais c'est beaucoup trop en
faire
merci du renseignement c'est casimir qui
s'est trompé de ça qui m'a laissé le
sien il a pris mien alors moi j'espérais
le trouver ici mais non casimir est déjà
tard puis avec le premier groupe
qu'est ce qui l'a mis dans ce gros sac
olala mais beaucoup de je l'aimais mais
c'est plein de choses inutiles on en
portera
à écouter les enfants les enfants
asseyez vous par ici et bien vous allez
me gêner asseyez vous voilà ce qui se
passe les enfants s'ils vous tout cela
voilà tout le monde est là alors voilà
ce qui se passe casimir et nous partons
faire un pique nique à la montagne ça
c'est le contenu du sac de casimir mais
voyez il emporté des tas de choses
inutiles alors on va naître d'un côté ce
qui sert à la montagne et pour un pique
nique et de l'autre suis complètement
d'une guilde accord alors voyons qu'est
ce que c'est que ça
c'est une bouée ça sert à la montagne
non alors rappelé à ceux ci
viennent de table pour le pique nique
c'est très bien tiens julie s'il te
plait ça une fourchette pour le pique
nique
ça qu'est ce que c'est que ça oui et ça
sert à quoi
oui où les mettons
sous les chaussures très bien donc ça
servira pour qu'elle signe à
ceux ci qu'est ce que c'est
un arrosoir ça sert plutôt
tu as raison ceci alors on ne
l'emportera pas ça nous encombre à ceux
ci qu'est ce que c'est
exactement on emporte
ça sert pour monter
et aussi pour redescendre qu'un jus 10
cl d'eau claire
ceci que ce que c'est
tu as tu as parfaitement raison et ça
s'appelle comment
ça s'appelle un piolet s'accroche comme
ça hop ce tir et puis avec ça aussi on
peut tailler des démarches dans la glace
qu'à juliet est ce qu'il nous reste
encore si c'est fou ce que casimir
peut-être remporté ceux ci qu'est ce que
c'est
ça c'est
louis nadal a donc eu à la piscine à la
mer en rivière ça sert surtout pour la
nage sous marines ont les emporte à la
montagne au plat
et une seule
c'est une gourde effectivement mais la
boisson pour se désaltérer qu'un joli
c'est vrai vous remercie les enfants
c'est très très gentil nous avoir aidés
à crier tous à vélo il restait un verre
oui on lui prend oui on peut l'emporter
mais moi je crois plutôt que c'est un
verre qu'on met sur une table de salle à
manger un plutôt qu'à la moule tahrir
parce que c'est un vagin on lui prend et
le banner bien sûr je le mettrais
d'ailleurs il est beaucoup mieux que le
mien bon ça les wallons merci beaucoup
julie dépêchons-nous il faut absolument
rattraper les ondes
beat mon âme s'en est allée au revoir
les enfants
oui c'est merveilleux rien par là non
plus mais c'est unique quel bonheur
près silence avec leur pique nique à la
montre ici le calme le plus absolu
j'ai bien fait de rester je vais enfin
pouvoir lire les aventures du chevalier
petits pois jeudi d'écossé a rien que
l'audit me fait déjà rire
[Rires]
du bruit mais c'est impossible le
facteur est pourquoi il n'est pas à
mettre les autres il va falloir que
j'aille vers au fond de ma mal si je
vais tranquille quelle guigne rend
l'album un aux
abeilles à personne oh bah c'est
formidable ça on mais je vais pouvoir me
reposer comme il faut c'est vrai au lieu
de gravir la montagne au milieu des
bêtes sauvages
je vais me préparer un bon petit repas
ensuite je ferai une petite sieste
et puis qu'un pourquoi pas au fait si je
me chantait ma chanson rang et ça serait
pas plus mal
[Musique]
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
meunier masson jalonnera
j'aurais pu même être chantre
j'aurais pu un truc qui va te copisur
mécanographe
mais j'ai choisi d'être acteur
quand je suis le roi seul d'orthographe
je suis l'ami des jolis mots
l'amoureux des phrases et ses vigan jeu
les emporte sur mon
cela me penche ont
voté
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
meunier à son rouge et or a
jamais pu même être chanteur
aurait pu être cultivateurs comprise ou
mécano bras
mais j'ai choisi d'être un facteur
je suis le roi de l'orthographe
j'aime les lettres
les écritures qui est charmante quand
leur taux gras frais respecter cela
montchamp
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
maniema sont bougés hogra
j'aurais pu même être champion
j'aurais pu être active at her
confiseurs pour mécano bras
mais j'ai choisi d'être factuel
je suis le roi de leurs programmes
dès que commence ce matin
tout le long du chemin
je chante
les gens jettent mon arrivée cela
montchamp
bon
enfin
j'aurais pu attendre les hackers veniez
masson rouge et au bras
j'aurais pu même être un chanteur
j'aurais pu être cultivateurs confiseurs
ou mais kalonas mais je choisis d'être
pas peur fort ce
prêt je choisis des tracteurs pour sûr
mais j'ai choisi d'être fatale
maintenant je vais faire ma petite
fiesta à
personne
je veux pouvoir me cacher et a
tendrement canaris rhône
tiens je me dis que je vais manger mon
sandwich
je vais me régaler mais
la question
à ces petits sandres riches
j'ai bien dormi
ça fait du bien au pas
qu'est-ce que tu ce qui arrive
nous demander le floutage un facteur
repas wand riches quand votre bonheur
brillant
mais vous allez voir
si je me dope
bon livre
un bon repas
comment voulez vous être plus heureux
oh